but how did you come up with the idea
the rapping like how did you think that
would sway them and get better grades so
I've been teaching for six years and
it's always a challenge every beginning
of the year and how to engage and
motivate the children so this year I
wanted to incorporate freestyling into
it because every single time I'd give
all my students free time they go on the
computer and look up beats and they just
go off in a rap you look very handsome
head to toe as well you look sharp right
now just letting you know but what do
you think about freestyle Fridays do you
like that
yes yeah freestyle Friday is that you
get you get to learn but you get you get
to play at the same time yeah you could
talk fun too
and school should be fun it should be
educational it should be a good time and
implement both those things together you
have a really great teacher right here
just letting you know do you like do you
like rapping what do you rap about money
money what is a beats and cars and these
fours in school all right all right you
know what you want you know what you
like I'm a fan of it Tosh so I kidding
y'all freestyle I cannot wrap for
anything everybody saw it on Billboard
Awards so I know that's my greatest fear
in life yeah
I most definitely cannot the Bravo my
boy Gronk can do it
to college at 2:00 a.m. I was always
rapping we all think we're great at
everything one time my friend recorded
me and I was like wow I'm awful like
amazing at that time at that moment you
think I'm a rapper I'm only a snapper I
get in a fight hit you in the face make
you a to gapper wait we said that in
front of them okay let's come back to
what we do I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this